hello welcome to science breakthroughs
from science mission I am sadashiva PI
and going to discuss couple of
breakthrough papers published in the
week of june second let's start first we
are going to discuss a paper published
by juan pablo in nature medicine on the
role of micro RNA in depression why this
paper is so important major depressive
disorder MDD is a prevalent mood
disorder affecting millions of people
this is the first study to report in
humans a consistent micro RNA
dysregulation in post-mortem brain
tissue and blood samples from
individuals with MDD changes in micro
RNA expression levels could predict drug
treatment response and could be a useful
biomarker authors analyzed micro RNA
expression in ventral lateral prefrontal
cortex that is PFC of individuals with
depression and identify my micro RNA
1202 as the most dysregulated micro RNA
with the decrease the expression in
depressed brains as shown in this figure
these findings were validated by
quantitative rt-pcr indicating decreased
micro RNA 1202 in human MDD subjects
authors found higher expression of micro
RNA 1202 in human brain as compared to
mine Creek brains and did not detect its
expression in veins of other species
authors also detected some expression of
micro RNA 1202 in all tissues but
expression was considerably enriched in
the brain this finding suggests a role
for micro RNA 1202 in cognitive
processes that are you need to primates
particularly humans gene targets of
micro RNA 1202 were predicted using 5
micro RNA target prediction databases
five genes were upregulated in the PFC
of subjects with depression
micro RNA 1202 levels correlated
negatively with the expression of grm
for but not with that of other predicted
genes erm for is expressed throughout
the brain and is localized pre and
postsynaptic ly where it modulates
glutamine ergic dopaminergic garba najuk
and serotonergic neurotransmission in
recent years grm for has been implicated
in the regulation of anxiety related
these behaviors authors used hek293
cells with no endogenous expression of
micro RNA 1202 and relatively high
levels of grm for to confirm the
interaction decrease grm levels after
transfection of micro RNA 1202 in
hek293t treatment of grm for agonist I
ap for in neural progenitor cells
reduced erm for expression whereas an
antagonist msop treatment increased
expression consistent with the
hypothesis micro RNA 1202 expression was
upregulated after I ap for treatment and
down-regulated after msop treatment this
result suggests a bi-directional
interaction between micro RNA 1202 and
grm for no effect of acute 24-hour
treatment with citalopram and imipramine
on micro RNA 1202 or gr m4 expression in
npc cells but an upregulation of micro
RNA 1202 after chronic treatment with
either drugs chronic treatment with
either antidepressant reduced grm for
mrna express
Shin authors found decreased micro RNA
1202 expression in blood samples of
patients with the depression and was
driven by the remitter group authors
explored the regulation of micro RNA
1202 by treating the patients with the
CT love palm the remitted group showed
increased micro RNA 1202 levels after
eight weeks of treatment whereas no
difference in micro RNA 1202 levels in
non-responders or controls change in
depression cvlt negatively correlated
with change in micro RNA 1202 expression
these findings confirm a relationship
between peripheral micro RNA 1202
expression and settler form treatment
response in patients with MDD to
conclude this is a very important study
and may help the patients with MDD next
let's look at another paper published by
a foo kyu in cell here authors identify
signaling pathways in the development of
fat why this paper is so important about
1.4 billion people are affected by
obesity globally imbalance between
energy intake and expenditure causes
obesity paper identify pathways that
could be targeted to alter energy intake
or expenditure human brown adipocytes
are cold inducible and interspersed
among white adipocytes in
supraclavicular para-aortic and
suprarenal regions they share some
molecular histologic and functional
characteristics with hold inducible BG
adipocytes found in subcutaneous white
adipose tissue that is SC what
of mice authors use ucp1 that is
uncoupling protein 1 staining of SC wat
oxygen consumption in wild-type controls
and mouse knockout models to demonstrate
the signaling pathways involved in the
generation of subcutaneous wat what has
investigated the role of type 2 immunity
in biogenesis of cold-induced beach fat
first by quantifying the expression of
thermogenic genes in SC wat of wild-type
and Inter looking for 13 knockout mom's
housed at various temperature for 48
hours quantitative rt-pcr analysis
revealed that prolonged exposure to
environmental cold that is at five
degrees Celsius induce the expression of
the core set of thermogenic genes and
reduced by 4 29 fold in SE wat of
interleukin 4 11 knockout mice
expression of ucp1 protein which is
required for uncoupled respiration in
brown and BJ deposits were increased
fourfold after cold exposure in AC wat
of wild-type but not in interleukin 4 13
knockout mice histological analysis
further affirm that cold-induced
remodeling of SC wat but not ye wat
oxygen consumption in AC wat and bat of
cold exposed mice confirmed the type to
cytokine signalling was preferentially
required for browning of subcutaneous
what
here the authors knocked out interleukin
alpha and sat six and show that you see
p protein levels were reduced and oxygen
consumption was affected in these mice
confirming the role of interleukin-4 are
alpha and stat6 in beach fat formation
author's generated for get mice with gfp
labeled use eosinophils gfp levels
increased at five degrees centigrade and
in the knockout mice that lack yersinia
fields Jeffy levels go down authors also
show that ucp1 use a novel staining of
TC wat and oxygen consumption were also
reduced in forget knockout mice
indicating the requirement of
eosinophils for fat generation author so
far have shown the activation of
interleukin and eosinophils from cold
next author show that monocytes which
are macrophages recruited at five degree
Celsius cold and in ccr to knockout mice
recruitment of monocytes and increase in
ucp1 oxygen consumption was prevented
authors also show that macrophages
express increase in alternate markers
like our genus 1cd 3c 301 interleukin 4
11 4 13 alternatively activate
macrophages
authors also demonstrate using
interleukin-4 ra and interleukin 4 are a
list to Cree knockout models that my
lord activation is required for the
generation of cold-induced Beach fat for
formation authors further demonstrate
and increase in tyrosine hydroxylase in
myeloid cells and knock out of tyrosine
hydroxylase in myeloid prevented
increased in ucp1 and oxygen consumption
authors thus have identified a pathway
that activation of beach fat formation
next authors wanted to investigate with
a pharmacological activation by
interleukin-4 was sufficient to increase
the total thermogenic capacity in thermo
neutral mice interleukin administration
increased UDP one and tyrosine
hydroxylase in SE wat and II wat but not
in bat and interleukin 4 knockout mice
these proteins did not increase
similarly oxygen consumption increased
following interleukin-4 administration
while mice exposed to increasing cold
temperature but not in interleukin
knockout mouse also norepinephrine
administration increased our oxygen
consumption in the presence of
interleukin 4 but not in interleukin 4
and UCP knockout mouse the trend is
reversed indicating their requirement
these findings demonstrate that
interleukin-4 mediated an increase in
beach fat must significantly contribute
to the thermogenic capacity of mice
since administration of interleukin for
selectively increased bit fat mass in
thermal neutral mouse authors
investigated whether this newly
recruited beach fat can ameliorate
metabolic dysfunction in the setting of
pre-established obesity thermal neutral
mouse were fed with normal chow that is
NC or high-fat diet that is hfd for 10
weeks my son hft were treated with
vehicle or interleukin-4 complexes over
a period of 14 days treatment treatment
with interleukin-4 decreased total body
mass and fat mass without significantly
affecting lean body mass as shown in
this figure hft feeding decreased
expression of tyrosine hydroxylase and
UCP proteins in the SE wat and yacht but
not in back which were restored after
interleukin-4 therapy these findings
were confirmed by histological
examination of SE wat and ewar of
treated animals authors investigated
whether interleukin-4 induced increased
in Beach fat mass can restore insulin
sensitivity in obese mice glucose and
insulin tolerance tests demonstrated
improvement in glucose disposal and
insulin sensitivity respectively in
interleukin-4 treated or base animals
this was further affirmed by proactive
insulin signaling studies which reveals
that interleukin-4 therapy improved
insulin action as quantified by the
phosphorylation of akt in E wat liver
and quadriceps these results demonstrate
that restoration of beach fat mass and
activity can mitigate pre-established
obesity and insulin resistance in mice
so this is an important study and may
have profound implication in the
treatment of obesity thank you for
watching science breakthroughs from
science